okay today i'm canceling the rock dwayne
johnson he is cancelled for various
high crimes and misdemeanors committed
in this instagram video which he posted
this week
from his weight room in case you guys
didn't know that the rock
likes to lift weights he made sure to
record the video in his weight room to
remind you
so here's what he had to say we have had
the biggest
voter turnout in the history
of the united states and you know that
is such a big deal because you know it
tells me number one we were unified on
that day and just in terms of
everybody coming together every
everybody uh coming out to vote
uh mailing in your ballots doing
everything you possibly can exercising
the democratic right to vote which was a
beautiful thing
but it also tells me that this is the
most engaged
our country has ever been in the history
again
of the united states so for the fact
that we can come together and be
disengaged
um and be unified on the day of voting
now we may of course we voted for
different people
but that's okay we still came out and we
voted uh i wanted to shoot this
yesterday
uh when the news broke but um
i i got a little emotional uh admittedly
so i got a little emotional uh yesterday
manly tears of course i may have cried a
tear or two or ten
uh but they were all very manly all my
tears have made me um
but the reason why i got emotional
yesterday was
was was because of what i felt my vote
represented
and i was talking to lauren my wife we
were talking about our two little baby
girls and and that's exactly what my
vote represented
my vote represented my little daughters
my vote represented
humanity my vote represented decency uh
it represented the values and the
principles
uh of which we we teach our little girls
and my vote also for me represented
the importance of just being a good
decent human being
okay so a lot of problems here first of
all um this stuff about how we should be
so proud and happy that all these people
voted i've already made my opinion on
that known i i don't see anything
especially praiseworthy or laudable or
desirable about the simple act of voting
the fact that lots of people do it is
not something to be celebrated in and of
itself
and if they're voting for a literal
dementia patient then that's even more
reason to refrain from
giving a standing ovation then he says
we voted for decency
whatever that means i'm still waiting
for evidence of this
mythical decency from joe biden but none
of that is the point
the real problem is that the rock says
he cried manly tears
over the election results no those tears
were not manly
the rock the term manly tears is
in almost all cases a contradiction a
non-sequitur it's self-refuting
there are precisely six exceptions to
this rule six times when a man may cry
we've already gone over this i think a
couple times somehow the rock didn't get
the memo
so we'll go over it again here are the
acceptable opportunities for a man to
cry these are the only six number one
death of an immediate family member
pretty self-explanatory
it has to be immediate family member
number two you get your arm stuck in a
wood chipper
i'm gonna allow the shedding of eight to
nine manly tears in that circumstance
don't overdo it though
don't abuse the privilege don't milk it
okay number three
uh the piece of sporting equipment that
you bonded with while stuck on a desert
island for three years drifted away
while you tried to row a makeshift raft
to safety
um for this i think tom hanks provides
an acceptable model
he of course had a full-on breakdown
sobbing screaming the whole enchilada
but it was okay because he had developed
a familial bond
with the volleyball in this case it
really falls under number one the death
of a family member
number four your firstborn son is
awarded the medal of honor or the
heisman
this is a time of tears of pride but
note where i stipulate first born it has
to be your firstborn
because if your second son gets it after
your first born son it's going to be old
news at that point
and you're going to kind of be annoyed
you're going to say hey get your own
thing live your own life all right
on the other hand if your second
achieves those honors but your first son
didn't your pride will be stained by the
bitter embarrassment of your oldest son
being such a disappointment by
comparison
i mean your younger son is a war hero
and your oldest son who you had such
high hopes for
is like working at chipotle this
disparity i think will ruin the moment
at least a little bit
number five you're trying to get out of
a speeding ticket this is controversial
i'm going to allow tears here it's never
worked for me
i should warn you and i have tried but
whatever whatever you have to do if it
works it works
by any means necessary if you can cry
your way out of an irs audit
two then more power too i'll allow that
as well
six finally a a uh a brief moment of
crying will be allowed upon the
completion of a long and arduous journey
to a long sought destination so say if
you're a 16th century explorer
sailing to the new world a future
astronaut reaching a new planet
or if you're me when i walk through
three terminals in atlanta to get to the
one restaurant the whole airport with
decent tacos
any of those scenarios or something
similar will constitute an appropriate
excuse to cry
however you will notice that your
favorite politician winning an election
is not on the list and i feel like i
should also mention that running out of
steroids
is also not on the list i'm not saying
that would be relevant to the rock i'm
just mentioning it for no reason
just throwing that in so uh the rock is
canceled along with any men who cry for
invalid reasons well i hope you enjoyed
that clip from the matt walsh show if
you did go ahead and hit that subscribe
button right down there so you can stay
up to date on all of our future content